es una decisión más dura de lo que había
pedido la fiscalía allixon rubén ala fue
condenado a 3 años de prisión dos de
ellos suspendidos y un año con brazalete
electrónico el veredicto se refiere a
varios cargos principalmente al uso de
lo que se ha considerado como fuerza
excesiva por parte del ex agente de
seguridad del elíseo durante las
protestas del primero de mayo de 2018 el
escándalo estalló después de que se
hicieran públicas las imágenes de
bengala llevando un casco de policía y
maltratando a los manifestantes una
fuente importante de incomodidad en
aquel momento para el presidente
emmanuel mayo que se tradujo en la
destitución de ben alí durante su juicio
en septiembre ven a la negó los cargos y
mantuvo que actuó por reflejo para
ayudar a los agentes de policía a
detener a los manifestantes
incontrolados sus abogados argumentaron
que sus acciones fueron proporcionadas
el ex guardia de seguridad también ha
sido declarado culpable de utilizar
ilegalmente pasaportes diplomáticos los
investigadores descubrir aunque siguió
utilizando los documentos para casi una
docena de viajes a pesar de que se le
pidió que renunciara a ellos algo que a
él mismo atestigua ante el parlamento en
septiembre de 2018
he cometido una serie de errores errores
que he reconocido de buena gana ante mi
familia y amigos ante quienes me rodean
y que he reconocido públicamente ante
ustedes y también he hecho lo mismo ante
los tribunales
otro de los cargos fue el porte ilegal
de armas de fuego basado en unos
comentarios de bengala y una foto suya
en un restaurante en 2017 la presidenta
del tribunal declaró que ven a la creía
que podía actuar con impunidad y que se
sentía todopoderoso durante su trabajo
para el presidente un abuso de poder y
responsabilidad que la llevó a dictar
una sentencia más dura que la de 18
meses solicitada por los fiscales